that a lot more. Yes, he did not need her consent. She wasn't
involved.
Again, my report is the same. If he violated the consent of another
person, then how is that not doing anything
The only two answers I can think of are that it's okay when Destiny
does it or it's okay when anybody does. Continuing to hurt him,
continuing to Hey, are you going to just talk forever? What's
Is there It just feels like I asked you DO YOU THINK
OKAY, MAX MAX ALREADY HAS A READ, OKAY? You can just talk forever,
can't you? Let me finish. We have two yes or no questions and
you need to decide what the answers are for the purpose of this
discussion. I'm asking you if you believe when want to answer
you. I don't care what you're asking me. Yes or no, for the
How can I say I don't care cuz I look in myself, I ask myself,
Max, do you care about what Extreme Dad's saying right now? And
I think no, I don't.
Mr. Girl, Extreme Dad, I think uh So, I watched the first, I
don't know, minute 30, minute 50 of this and
Extreme Dad comes in and says like, I want you I want you to
help me make my argument for like why uh we should feel bad for
Destiny. So, that'd be funny. I think this would be funny. Just
to watch Mr.
videos with uh person who was not
you know
uh
agreed to be involved in seeing them.
Oh, we can also speed up quite a bit. Let's Let's not Let's not
Let's not talk about what we think about what he did. Let's just
nail down what we think he did first.
What? Oh, what we think about what he
Let's say what he did. Okay. Sorry, I For a second, I thought
he said the same thing twice. I was a little confused there.
We're good. We're good. He shared
videos of Pixie without her explicit consent. Do you think that
Destiny believed he had her implicit consent?
Yes, I do. Absolutely. I believe that Destiny believed that.
Okay, if you Um that's just obviously not true, right? That's
obviously not true and it's just very funny that um
Like that The funny thing is is apparently Destiny's just going
to lie, right? He's just going to lie and say he thought he had
her explicit consent or that he had her implicit consent that
it was obvious he could share it with anybody, but he's just
going to lie. There's no part of who Pixie is as a person that
actually supports that whatsoever, right? Like it's just clearly
not true and
it's it's clearly not true in multiple dimensions. Pixie, when
the Lav stuff came up in Lav who Destiny clearly yapped to Lav
about that happening,
Because if you don't know, Lav actually had heard about other
partners of Destiny and other partners of Destiny have talked
about how he sort of reveals these things that are supposed to
be private. So, in any case, he um he's talked about these things
and
oh man, yeah, I'm not going to It's just so annoying. So, when
when the thing happened with Lav in 2024, that was the moment
where he should have gone, "Oh, wait, Pixie, I don't have Pixie's
consent to send it to these things." He should have thought,
right? Cuz he didn't say, "Hey Pixie, actually I sent this I
sent the video that you said that you you know, we both agreed
we could share. I sent that video. Yeah, there might be multiple
people who know about you actually cuz it's got your face in
it and obviously
yeah, there there might be multiple people who know." But he
didn't do that. He said, "No, no, only Melina would know on my
end." Because that's what he actually agreed to. Why does that
map perfectly to what was actually agreed
instead of him just telling the truth there in 2024.
If fine. You believe that, why did he tell her that he betrayed
her trust in the worst way?
Because he felt bad. And that's what he said. Why did he feel
bad?
Beca- Oh, it's just going to be my conversation again, isn't
it? who you care about who you think Don't don't answer in this
format. Just directly answer. Why did Destiny feel bad? I answered
that. Okay. Did Did Destiny feel that he betrayed her trust in
the worst way?
Mhm. Probably not. No. Okay. So, he He mean that.
Oh, what?
If if we're being like Please just answer. I'm not going to I'm
not going to I'm not going to have If you can't answer these
questions, I'm not going to talk to you about this. He didn't
mean Okay. So, he was placating her. He did not mean that. Yes,
he was placating. As you do. Well, I'm not sure. Well, he wasn't
even No, no, no. He wasn't placating her. That's actually because
he wasn't talking to Pixie.
HE WAS TALKING TO STRAIGHT A Raid. How in the Are you saying
that he's placating Pixie when he's talking to Straight A Raid?
Why would he be placating Pixie? He's not.
What is this? If I thought I had someone's consent to share a
video and then they found out that I shared it, I would probably
say something like "Oh, I thought that was okay with you." Not
"I know I betrayed your trust in Wait, let me say If you can't
If you interrupt me, I'm not going to talk about it. If I thought
I had someone's consent, I would say, "Oh, I thought you were
cool with me sharing this video." I wouldn't say, "I betrayed
your trust in the worst way. Do you want $50,000 or whatever?"
So, it's it's hard for me to agree with you about what happened
when the evidence suggests that he did not have her implicit
consent. The evidence for him not having her implicit consent
are uh other women saying that he didn't have their consent and
that this was all done kind of secretly and covertly. Uh Pixie
filing a lawsuit against him. Uh Pixie, I think, and and and
or maybe others um filing criminal complaints against him. Uh
Pixie refusing to um accept a settlement from him and saying
that it would not be painful enough to teach him to never do
this again. And Destiny himself saying that he betrayed her trust.
So, these these Straight A Raid is the biggest rat in all of
this? No, she's not. Not even remotely. How could you call Straight
A Raid the biggest rat when she was acting like basically
I think she was Straight A Raid just thinks everybody's being
like overly emotional. Straight A Raid is like uh what do you
call it?
Uh there's probably a word for it, but Straight A Raid is like
she just thinks, "Oh, everybody's being like too emotional about
this, right?" Which is basically her natural setting, which is
But she wasn't like she was talking to people she was extremely
close to, right? Like super close friends with. And those people
just totally betrayed her trust, which she was betraying Pixie's
trust, but I think there's probably when huge things happen,
you would actually talk to other people,
And one of the people she was friends with was Sunday, and Sunday
totally violated totally destroyed her trust,
That's that's the sad thing is is she thought Sunday was her
close friend, and Sunday just took like what he told what she
told him and was like, "Yeah, I'm I'm literally putting that
anywhere
But apparently apparently the other people are doing it, too,
that might have had it. So, I don't know. Unlucky. These all
just don't talk. These all read to me as strong evidence
he did not have her implicit consent. And he did not think he
had her implicit
So, I think until we can agree I think until we Wait, what did
he just say? These all read to me as strong evidence
he did not have her implicit consent. And he did not think he
had her implicit
So, I think until Well, no, that all wouldn't be evidence he
didn't think he had implicit consent. I think the 2024 thing
when he never updates his like he never lets Pixie know, obviously
I've let some other people see it. You we kind of like we I thought
we had an understanding there, right? When he refuses to update
Pixie in 2024,
that's where everything breaks.
It's a very weird way of justifying her talking to President
Sunday when he's well known for doing this exact thing.
Um no, I'm basically explaining human emotion and how humans
process like big things happening in their lives, Kelly.
Uh I'm definitely not justifying it at all. I'm not saying I'm
literally that was bad. Justifying it would say, "Oh, it's okay
that she did it." But I actually will just say, "No, that was
really stupid." I think I've called her on stream like eight
different times.
But um Kelly again, just, you know, she doesn't parse English
in the way that regular humans do. Until we can agree I think
until we can agree on what happened, I probably am not going
to be able to help you. Let's say that he didn't have her implicit
consent. These I still think that him sharing those videos Well,
let's let's I don't want to know I don't I don't want to know
what I don't want to hear what you think. I want to nail down
for the this conversation what the premises of what happened.
Cuz when you start combining how you feel about what happened
with what you think happened. Yeah, I don't know. I just think
Pixie's feelings in the matter are more important than whatever
Jstock thinks. LOL. Okay. Nobody asked. Nobody cares. Irrelevant
to the conversation we just had. Thank you, KELLY. AS USUAL.
Then you start Okay, you start saying things that you start saying
things that don't make sense. So, Let's say for argument's sake
that he shared the videos without explicit or implicit consent
and in direct violation of her trust in him and and that he was
stop over explaining things. Did Destiny have her implicit consent?
No. Did Destiny think he had her implicit consent? No. If you
want to say for the purpose of argumentation or discussion or
assuming he did not have her consent and he did not think he
had her consent. So, you think that when he sent the videos he
knew and deliberately agree on terms, if you can't agree on a
premise for this conversation, then we can't have it. I don't
want I don't want to I I don't want to argue about this with
you. I You said for the purpose of argumentation and then you
you put forward a premise, but then you just started kind of
talking a lot and not actually settling not actually settling
on a premise. We have two yes or no questions and you need to
decide what the answers are for the purpose of this discussion.
I'm asking you if you believe when he had her to answer you I
don't care what you're asking me. Yes or no. For the purpose
How can I say I don't care? Cuz I look in myself. I ask myself,
Max, do you care about what ExtremeDad's saying right now? And
I think no, I don't. I I know I don't care. a resource for me.
Your viewer There There are terms and conditions for me being
a resource. The first term is you have to be able to you have
to be able to clearly articulate what the [__] you're
talking about. Shared was just gossip maxing with Sunday, nothing
else. I don't think so, but hey.
Why What leads you to believe that, SSS? I mean, I should probably
just do collins or something if people are going to say really
rude things, what makes you think that she was just gossip maxing?
What part of that conversation makes you think she was just gossiping?
She was? She's literally asking for She was literally asking
for advice on how to help things, right?
Like like she didn't know how to act and she was asking for advice.
She was like, "There's a really complicated situation." Probably
because she probably trusted Destiny before that, right? She
probably thought he was somebody you could trust with some stuff.
And obviously, she was like, "Oh, I'm probably I'm going to talk
to somebody who I know doesn't trust Destiny, who didn't think
Destiny was trustworthy." Doesn't that make sense? If you If
you find out that Destiny is super untrustworthy, he's a total
piece of [__] Does it not make sense to look at people
who maybe thought he was a total piece of [__] before
that
Does that not make any sense at all? I feel like that makes perfect
sense to me, but I would I would love to know from other people
why they think that doesn't make sense.
Anyway, I'll continue with this. can't do that, then I can't
help you. I tried to clearly articulate it, but you keep cutting
me off.
You said You crossed an irreversible line about 30 seconds ago
when you said that? You said, "Let's say for the purpose of argumentation."
And you're about to outlay You're about to lay out a premise.
And now you have to say what the premise is. And you have to
do so by answering two yes or no questions. God, Kelly just does
the most non sequiturs all the time. I I have to actually not
watch my chat right now. Did Destiny have Pixie's consent to
share the videos?
Second question. Did Destiny believe he had Pixie's consent to
It's not possible for me to speculate on, but I would say for
you to speculate. It No, it's not. I'll say no, just No, no.
You're You're knee-capping your own ability to think or speak
coherently.
When you are not willing when you Let me Let me Let me Let me
explain how stupid what you just said is. You want to have a
conversation presumably about the ethics of Destiny's behavior
and the response that he Kelly you Kelly ran from the argument.
Why make an argument when you just call everything a Okay, um
basically Kelly, so everything you've been saying is just totally
totally nonsense, right? Like extremely low IQ When you say it's
fine to think what StraightRage did is a bit worse than just
being stupid. Just like it's fine to think Destiny sending some
tapes to randoms is worse than just being stupid. That is not
actually a statement that is relevant to any conversation that's
ever been had anywhere. That Nobody disagrees with that. You
just say something that like is basically un-falsifiable as if
it's an argument, but it's not actually related to any conversation
being had and you either know that and are doing that intentionally
to I guess stall or spin off in a different direction, or you're
doing it unintentionally because you're too low IQ to understand
that they're not related.
And I'm not sure which one it is. he's getting and the blowback
he's getting and the potential legal consequences and civil consequences
and criminal consequences. And but you want to have this conversation
with the premise that none of us can speculate over Destiny's
mind state or whether he actually had her consent or believed
he had Sorry, whether he believed he had her consent. Even though
that is pivotal to any ethical evaluation of his behavior.
I just explained to you that that is not related. What we're
what we were originally conversing about is I was saying this
is why I sort of understand what happened with StraightRage.
I don't think it's good. I think it's bad. And your thought was,
"Well, I think it's okay to think it's dumb." Yeah, nobody asked.
Nobody That was never a part of the conversation. You're just
saying things that nobody asked and don't contribute to the conversation
moving forward. You do this quite often, actually. Well, no,
I want to speculate about it, but you're asking me a yes or no
question, and I'm it's impossible for me to say what Destiny
believed at the time, of course. But yes, Maybe you're con- Maybe
you're confused of Maybe you forgot what we were talking about.
You said that you wanted to set a premise for the discussion.
So, to set a premise, we have to agree on what happened. And
part of what happened is whether Destiny believed that he had
her consent. So, the premise of the conversation needs to decide
did Destiny believe he had her implicit consent Okay, Kelly,
who are you talking to, Kelly?
Who are you talking to, Kelly?
Go ahead. Tell me who you're talking to.
Multiple people in the chat.
I also would I also would refrain from naming somebody specifically.
needs to decide did Destiny believe he had her implicit consent
or not. And if you can't answer that question, then you can't
have the conversation. My conversation was more about like I
don't care. You You crossed You No, you crossed It's an irre-
No, no, it's an irreversible step you took. You said, "Okay,
let's say for let's You said, "Let's say for the sake of argument."
And when you When those words left your mouth, you ended You
ended the previous You ended the previous conversation. I'm not
going to engage with you about anything other I'm not going to
I'm not going to engage with you about anything other than the
rest of that sentence. What are we saying for the sake of argument?
And if it turns out, as I suspect, that you're not actually willing
to set a premise for what happened, then my advice to you is
that you need to do some soul searching or something until you're
willing to set a framework for how to even think about this.
agree to that, but but the No, no, I'm not I'm not asking you
I'm not asking you if you're willing to agree. I'm asking you
two yes or no questions that you are seemingly incapable of answering.
The You're incapable of answering. You're I'll ask you I'm going
to ask you again. If you cannot answer in just yes or no, I'm
going to end the call. Are you ready? I'm ready.
For the purpose of this discussion, we need to decide on two
things as premises.
You are not deciding what literally happened, and you're not
being asked to mind read anyone or disrespect anyone by presuming
to know what they were
The two questions I'm about to ask you are strictly for the purpose
of setting up a premise as a as a jumping off point
from which to have the conversation you want to have. And the
two questions are Okay, the two questions are Did Destiny have
Pixie's implicit consent to share their videos?
Did Destiny believe he had Pixie's implicit consent to share
their videos?
Wait, why would you say no?
I don't think I don't think Max was really trying to get him
to say no, but that like why would That That's nullified the
need for the conversation. If he's just going to say no to both
of those things, then he doesn't actually believe any of the
arguments he was coming on to ask about.
I'm confused.
That was a great setup, and I I I like where how you worded that.
Thank you. And so going forward with that Yeah. Do Do we believe
that he would
with disregard for her for her privacy? You You dropped out for
a second. Do we believe that he acted with reckless disregard?
Is that what you're saying? Yeah, reckless disregard for her
privacy by sharing it with one person in a private conversation,
someone he knew and could believe to keep it confidential between
them. Okay. So now we have some new premises we need to iron
out. Some some more yes or no questions.
Do you believe that this is the only person he shared the video
with?
Is that the premise?
Probably not. Okay. So the premise is this is not one person
he shared the video with. He shared the video with multiple people.
Second premise, do you consider the allegedly 19-year-old
that he was to be someone that he knew?
You said You said he didn't just share it with somebody. He it
with someone he knew. So, I'm wondering what the threshold for
knowing someone is and what the difference is functionally between
sending it to this person and sending it to a random person that
he that he doesn't enough to share his own intimate details,
his own private information that would be I forgot what streamer
DM or whatever Destiny said Rose was a close friend. He said
it to Pixie. He said, "I only sent it to this one close friend
and that like I obviously trusted them, right? I've talked to
them on the phone a lot." He He He just lied multiple times to
Pixie directly. damaging to him what Based on him Based on what
we have learned about Destiny over the years, do you think Destiny
has a high bar for who he is willing to send images to? Or do
you think Destiny is a sociopath who compulsively sends images
to dozens or hundreds of different women that he does not know
very well?
Or is it Is there a third option that I haven't thought of?
I think that it's probably somewhere in the middle and I don't
think that there's anything necessarily wrong with that. I didn't
say there was anything wrong with it. We're just evaluating whether
whether saying is this is someone he knew makes sense.
It's a loaded question. It's not a loaded question when you say,
"Is it A, B, or some other option that I've not thought of yet?"
That is
literally can't be a loaded question because you've said if you
don't think it's either of these things, give me your option.
How is that How can that possibly be a loaded question?
He didn't say you have to pick one or the other. He said A, B,
or some C that you can define.
I think that this is someone that he has spoken to at length
and could reason You labeled him a sociopath in the second option.
Yes. So, you would say C.
Don't believe he accepts The one you can define. to keep his
private
details private.
Okay. So, if you were in Destiny's shoes, you would do the same
thing
you know, there's not that much risk.
Yes, actually. I I believe that I believe that I probably would
have done the same thing believing that there was not that much
risk And I think that that's a reasonable interpretation.
Okay. And so you think when this stuff leaked, Destiny was like,
"What? I never thought that this could leak." Absolutely, I think
that that's what he Yeah. 100% I think that. That's what he's
shocked that that's He's he's he's shocked, I tell you. He's
shocked that any of this stuff would come out. I'll be honest,
I'm shocked that nothing had leaked with stuff like this in the
entire time he was doing it. It's actually It is actually shocking.
Like the the prevalence of uh not with the the Pixie tape, okay?
Not with the Pixie tape as much because um like I think Pixie's
had a hard time finding somebody. That one, I don't know why
that one was sent in like so little of the time, but with a lot
of the other videos and the especially the voice recording stuff
of like him sucking or like like that stuff seems to be sent
to everybody, right?
Destiny was giddy, dude. Farha read him like a book when she
said he likes to sneak brag about his con- conquests. Oh, yeah.
Do you Hold on. Do you think um Do you think there's like any
Do you think there's
Why do you think Farha was on stream?
Right? Like realistically, he doesn't The reason he doesn't like
that you point out that he tell the people like he meets and
stuff is because
you're literally pointing out his ti- Like he is explicitly doing
that because he's had
sex with them, okay? Like There there are people who will come
on his stream who you've never met before. What was the girl's
name who was on before? Well, who is the girl the the Only Fans
girl? It was like Anya Anya Daystar or That girl.
That girl he brought on right before the Fuentes debate where
he went and debated Fuentes on the JQ and got his ass blown out
by Fuentes and then started saying like, "Well, uh What hap-
I forget exactly how it went down. We were talking about this
the other day in some like some other channel. But he um he literally
said there's some dude born in New York in like 1930." And he's
like and Destiny like Google Nick was talking Fontes was talking
about this guy and Destiny like Google's him, looks up his Wikipedia
and goes, "This guy wasn't even born in Israel. And you're making
Why are you saying this stuff about him? He wasn't even born
in Israel." It's
Israel didn't exist.
It literally did not exist.
Yeah. So, that debate where he got his ass owned by Fontes. That
I think it was Anya Daystar. Like that person was only on the
stream because they had sex with them, right? And I guarantee
you he would have asked them, "Hey, you should come on stream."
Yeah. Hawkgirl, just Yeah, come on stream. Come on stream with
me. Right
Okay, black pill. Nobody cares. Nobody asked, nobody cares.
And embarrassed and uh
Oh, somebody's saying um they asked him, "Hey, you send stuff
to people really quickly. Aren't you worried that somebody will
leak it?" And Destiny's response was, "Uh women are generally
just really trustworthy in my
Interesting. Upset and violated and uh dealing with a really
difficult situation that was compounded by the fact that he also
hurt this person that he cared about and Um Kelly, yeah, I'm
saying like the people who go to his apartment or something.
Like I'm sure he just asked a lot of them to come on stream.
Right? That's why Anna was on stream. That's why all these people
come on stream.
I don't I don't know if you've been in his apartment or something.
Maybe you've been in his apartment and on the stream or something.
I've no idea. was intimate with and who trusted him and was No,
no, no, no. The funny thing is Amax secure. When I say that,
it's funny because he goes, "Okay, um No, no, no. Women Yeah,
I Yeah, I've only known you for like 2 weeks and sending you
this stuff, you know, that's kind of dodgy. But women are just
really trustworthy in my experience." Kind of goes totally against
his whole like, oh, these women are all lying horrors. You know
what I'm saying?
That's all. That's all. Do you know Aubrey? I mean, I don't believe
her, but if regardless was
indicating that she was severely upset and hurt by this. And
so not only is he hurt, she's hurt, and the situation is compounded,
and he has this public backlash that was just like
you know, everybody turning on him and just I think you know,
there was a little bit of a of a uh
I don't want to say power grab, but a little bit of a vacuum
that might be created by his his downfall, and people kind of
like you
maybe maybe desired that a little bit, and so they used this
to kind of uh you know I don't know. I just think that uh
I think that it's often it I
not even often. I think that everyone really is overlooking the
fact that
uh who did not have permission, you know, it's not like he shared
these videos with whoever Rose's boyfriend is. Um you know, somebody
who did not have permission his permission to view his private
messages and videos including on his phone got got access to
them and tried to uh hold him hostage, tried to like tried to
get on stream to embarrass him publicly. Like literally was you
know, blackmailing him. And he it at the very least Oh, hold
on. Apparently this is from the Bob 7 manifest. So, one
He screen shared those nudes with Bows cuz he's trying to Bows
cuz he wants to get on her good side. One of the ways to do that
is to show nudes of other women. 100% that's what happened.
Wow, that's a really crazy
funny opinion to have.
The way you The way you women is by showing them nudes of other
women.
Huh. Well, I'm going to I'm going to go ahead and copy-paste
this.
Where's like Pixie's DMs? Hold on. No, no, no. Actually, wait.
Where's the Where's the DM with like Pixie and Pixie's lawyers
and all of the people who are getting to lie about Destiny? Oh,
there it is. Okay. Yeah, I'll send it to that group chat. Pixie
will get it from that one.
Do you think that was sarcastic enough or do you think um do
you think people will take that seriously? I don't know.
Oh, listen to it again. I'll listen to it again. cuz he's trying
to expose cuz he wants to get on a good side. And one of the
ways to do that is to show nudes of other women. 100% that's
what happened.
That's That's crazy.
That's You go through this guy's like history and there's just
so many things like that. It's very, very funny.
I feel like the funny thing is is
if this does go to a jury
like stuff like this will be played in front of a jury, right?
Like this Dude, you can paint the most
I I just personally would never want to get in front of a jury
for this kind of
if I were Destiny, but
oh well. with stood that and didn't like make it into a bigger
public spectacle by caving and giving this guy what he wanted
and and causing even further damage to Pixie, you know, at least
he had the backbone to stand up to this guy and say, "No, [__]
you. If you're going to do it, do it." I don't know how many
of us would have had that same level of a you know
you know, who would have been able to withstand the same pressures.
I don't know how many people would have said, "No, [__]
you. Go ahead and release all my [__] if you want.
I'm not going to give you what you want." You know, I think a
lot of people would have caved and would have let the dude on
stream and it would have been an even bigger public spectacle
and an even worse problem for both of them. But, I think that
has handled this to the best of his ability and I think that
it's a it's an incredibly difficult situation to be in. And as
you know, I'm not you know, me and Destiny are not on great Did
you see the little DGG log receipt? I was embarrassed in court
because the judge knew I [__] the crazy girl. Okay,
no.
It's bizarre. We're not pals or anything like that. I'm not a
a DGG'er. I'm not even I'm banned I've been banned from this
community. You know, he calls me a violent psychopath. Uh You
know, we're not friends. So, I'm not I'm not saying this as someone
who who
you know, has anything to to gain here. But outside looking in
I just think that there's a lot of people putting a lot of
burden on him to be the bad guy here. When in reality it's just
a [__] situation for everyone involved. And there's
nothing to be gained by this lawsuit. There's nothing to be gained
by you know, can So, now extreme dad is actually arguing now,
okay, that Destiny didn't have consent. He didn't think he had
consent. So, Pixie's like objectively wronged and objectively
winner within her rights to sue. But he is still maintaining
despite these things he's admitted to that apparently there's
just no reason to have this lawsuit. There's nothing to be gained
from this lawsuit.
Continuing to hurt him, continuing to Hey, are you going to just
talk forever? What's Is there It just feels like I ASKED YOU
OKAY, MAX MAX ALREADY HAS A READ, OKAY? You can just talk forever,
can't you? Yeah, you can. I can see it. You can just talk forever.
Got me bottled up for so long. Okay, give me 2 seconds. I'm getting
some more caffeine. I'm uh
I need to stop. So, I I take these
antihistamine pills or whatever to sleep sometimes. Like if I'm
if I'm up late and I need to go to sleep and like the sun's up
and [__] I'll And then I just for the first like
4 hours I'm awake, I'm dead. So, I'm just going to get more caffeine
and see if I can power through it. Give me a second. I'll I'll
be right Just like I had all this stuff I asked you if you thought
that it was reasonable for Destiny to believe that this would
not leak and if you think he was shocked that that I think that
was the last thing I said. And then it's just like
you know.
I mean everything I said is a fair question. but What you're
saying is a
So, I don't I don't understand I'm I'm here to ask you for help
in constructing my
How can I better empathize with Destiny and and convey to people
that Well, it sounds like you sounds like you're feeling quite
empathetic towards Destiny already. So, I don't know what you
mean. You mean how to get other people to empathize with Destiny?
Yeah, how can I better
get other people to uh in the situation?
Well, I think you if you're trying to understand how Destiny
is internally feeling, I think you might be missing the mark
a bit by No, I I'm not and I don't need to.
I don't think that's necessary.
Anyone in that situation
I would agree with. If it was Hitler that this happened to, I
would say, "Wow, that's really [__] up."
I don't know how that's a response to what I just said.
I don't need to understand how Destiny's feeling internally to
empathize with him?
Maybe I don't understand what empathize means. And you're What
do you mean by Can you rephrase it then?
I don't need to know how what he's thinking, how he's feeling,
or tell me what you're is what you are trying to accomplish.
When I go on like J's doctor or Kleiman's stream and I argue
with people and I say like, "Hey, maybe you just have Uh so,
what ExtremeDad means here, okay? What he actually mean is he
wants to say that regardless of mind state or how good a bad
bad a person is, he thinks that somebody being put into this
situation just regardless of intent, regardless of what they
were doing is wrong. Um this obviously given that he's already
allowed the loading that like Destiny did this intent like knowing
he didn't have any consent whatsoever. It's obviously like a
completely I don't understand how he got this far into the conversation.
It's very I'm just super confused.
I'm trying to
convince more people that
this is actually a
bad thing for everyone involved and that Destiny didn't really
do anything wrong.
I'm trying to convince people Destiny is an innocent angel who
did nothing wrong.
So, the question from here is, why, given you've already given
up, you've already admitted to Max in this conversation, that
you think he didn't think he had consent? So, why, despite despite
him doing something clearly wrong, why do you Yes, it is extreme
dad. We're listening to extreme dad.
I know, low-hanging fruit, but it somebody posted in my subreddit,
and
it's never it's never a bad idea to get this kind of content
in an early in the stream, okay?
I mean, I don't agree with the premise that he didn't have her
consent, and didn't believe he had her consent.
It doesn't Okay. Well, I think that that's probably where you
need to start. If he violated the consent of multiple other people,
how is he an innocent angel?
Because in our society, we are violating each others consent
and boundaries, and you know, there's this laissez-faire
Oh, MAN. Extreme dad's arguments are crazy.
these things all around.
you know, It seems Bro, Max got blown the [__] up
in Destiny's community for saying that I'm pretty sure this girl
wanted me to [__] her, okay? I'm pretty sure this
girl wanted me to [__] her, but she did say no, and
then I [__] her anyway. Like, that's that's Max got
blown up for that situation, right? And he's like, wait, where
is this okay?
It's different as a physical situation, I understand, but like,
where where do we just allow consent violation all over the place?
Adrenaline kicks in about 14 hours later, unfortunately.
Ah, I don't think about that, but
Didn't Pixie violate, too? I see no evidence of that, Zaza.
I see no evidence of that. I It's particularly concerning that
Destiny started using that argument, given that Pixie responded
with the responded saying that was untrue, like weeks or months
ago. Right? So, it's been it's been an argument Pixie has said,
"No, no, no. Um I had consent from Destiny to send this video
to my boyfriend who he knew I was with and who he like knew we
were doing this whole shared thing with, right?"
She said that months ago.
So, I don't know what she said on the stand that conflicts with
the statement she gave months ago, but that's that's like explicitly
it's in text from months ago.
That she she said, "I know Destiny gave me permission to share
it with my boyfriend." He published them to the internet. It's
not like he was swapping them like a bunch of Playboys. I don't
think you're answering my question. essentially rapists.
Okay, what I don't think that anything here
chance about being Uh Zaza, even if he even if she misspoke on
the stand, which we have no proof of, we just have Destiny's
word, which I don't know if you've realized is literal dog [__]
But even if she misspoke on the stand, like she has a written
statement from before where she said she did have that
It's been mentioned multiple times, so.
The question was, "How is he an innocent angel if you believe
that he knowingly violated the consent of another person?"
Well, I was using hyperbole when I said that. Like I when I what
I mean is it's just that like I don't think that he did
wrong. You tell me when you have figured out the phrasing that
you're ready to
I And then you tell me what that is, and then and then I'll give
you my I believe that what he did was understandable given the
circumstances.
And I think that people are being unfair in their assessment
of his guilt, and I want to be Stop rambling. Please stop rambling.
Just one sentence about how wrong what Destiny did is.
I think that given the circumstances actions were understandable
and okay.
Hold on, one second. His argument about Pixie being one that
should had that should have lawyers take down his vids is so
[__]
Yeah, sure. Obviously obviously that's like uh
I don't know yeah, obviously it's silly. Obviously it's weird
that they were willing to allow that motion through and then
opposed it after she said no no no, you'd have to pay for this.
Right? And sorry, if they only opposed by the way, if they only
opposed Pixie's motion for um getting the thing taken down because
of the fees, I actually would have maybe supported Destiny's
side on that. Um because that would have been actually kind of
wrong. But they they they didn't just oppose on that, they opposed
on like the grounds of how valid it was to do that.
Which is crazy to me.
Uh do do do do do do do. Wasn't the argument that Pixie sent
content that had Destiny in it without his consent? That was
the argument, yes. But I'm saying Pixie has said from the beginning
of this case, like from months ago, she it's on the record that
she said no, Destiny gave me his consent to send this content.
And he never bothered making a big deal out of it or saying that
that wasn't true or anything along those lines. It's very concerning.
Uh spoilers, but he specifically said today that the reason he
opposed it was because they wouldn't take his stuff
Why did why does he believe they have the authority to take his
stuff down?
I'm asking you to make a moral evaluation. Did Destiny do something
wrong? So it has to be something like Destiny didn't do anything
wrong, Destiny did something wrong, Destiny did something a little
wrong. It has to be something like that.
Uh I I'd probably have to I have I'd have to just wrong arm it
and say no, I don't think I'd pay. Given the circumstance. Okay,
so even though you're qualifying it by saying you'd have to strong
arm it, are you prepared to defend your stance that Destiny did
not do anything
Yeah, and I think that's what this is all about. So
Again, my retort is the same. If he violated the consent of another
person, then how is that not doing anything
The only two answers I can think of are that it's okay when Destiny
does it or it's okay when anybody does it.
It's okay because
there's no alternative. It's not like Destiny could say, "Hey
Pixie, do you mind if I share the video of you and I with this
girl that I 19-year-old Discord kitten?" Nobody does that. So,
there's no there no reasonable uh uh method for him or or way
for him to qualify or get her consent without
Yeah, there is.
And unfortunately for Extreme Dad, we literally have the peach.
By the way, if somebody has those like peach vids where people
were arguing, somebody has those. Could you send me a link to
them? So, the one where we're arguing about uh like people who
were saying peach leaked this stuff and she said, "No, no, no,
Destiny gave me consent to share it with share it with partners.
That's the agreement we made." Apparently, he knows exactly what
this conversation looks like because he set up this this exact
consenting
uh sharing arrangement with Baby Peach and said, "Hey, we're
we recorded videos together. Do you mind if I share it with my
partners and you can share it with your partners?" So, he knows
what that argument what that arrangement looks like, right? He
has described that arrangement. He has made that arrangement
with other people. He has expressed that he's made that arrangement
with other people even when it was embarrassing for him to do
so. So, he understands how to get consent to share these videos
even with other partners, right?
But, there's no evidence of him doing that in the Pixie case.
Isn't Okay, no, you know that's not true, Rile. making me look
like a weirdo freak and we're alienating her out and and alienating
her. So, he has Uh he said today that he gave no consent to Pixie.
Yeah, he is just going to lie, Anakin. He is a lizard, right?
He is a totally
emotionless, unfeeling lizard who is just lying. He never He
never would have said that before. He didn't say it before when
Pixie said those exact things, right?
Pixie has made it clear from the very beginning that she shared
those things back with her boyfriend because that was a part
of the arrangement they had. And he's just saying, "No, no, no,
like uh that didn't happen."
Like he he's just he's just lying.
He's just willing to lie. Um and he has no downside of lying
because like he's he's just totally committed in that direction.
Uh like like basically he's decided that he wants to win the
PR battle. So he's just going to make up whatever he wants,
Hope he can get it dismissed in summary judgment, which I don't
know. Maybe that maybe that works. I don't think it works unless
they can basically make Abby have like a an emotional breakdown
or something, which is probably what they're trying to do.
Right? They'll they'll continue trying to do that.
Um I actually kind of expect that he's going to make this content
as much as possible now. I wouldn't be shocked if they like get
Darius to fill out an affidavit, get like Darius's roommates
to fill out affidavits. I would expect that's the direction they're
going to go in is they're going to try to make as much content
out of the uh court case as possible and try to get people to
yeah, basically just make it um as big a spectacle as possible.
That's what I would expect from them.
But we'll see how it goes. has to kind of operate on this uh
you know, loose understanding of what It sounds like you're about
to violate the premise cuz the premise was that he knew he did
not have her consent. And that he did not have it and he knew
he didn't have it. So for him to get it.
Okay. So it is okay to violate someone's consent when there is
no way to get it. Actually, this might be wrong. I might because
maybe I don't know if she did say that like explicitly do not
share these with anybody. Um that would be that would be explicit
non-consent, which was not one of our premises. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Then in that case, yeah, there was no way for him to get it.
So there was no So it is okay so so your stance is it is okay
to violate consent when there is no way to get it.
Uh how much do you think Pixie can get money-wise if she wins?
Uh I think stuff like what's going on with regards to the witnesses
and constantly, you know, making fun of Pixie and getting, you
know, DGG like enabling DGG doing it, like not ever doing any
sort of like, "Hey, don't do this." Do you remember when it first
started out and he was like, "No, no, no, you guys should never
ever harass somebody like this. Never harass anybody." What was
the exact quote? It's like, "Never say it's okay to send this
without consent. Never ever do any of this. Don't defend what
I'm accused of. Don't do any of that, right? And then he he's
totally like reversed on that because he somehow thinks that
there's like a massive conspiracy against him. He's basically
like a QAnon type person now. Um
and he's totally reversed on that. And the harassment from DGG
is pretty bad. We're joking about her herself in there like quite
a bit the other day, right? Uh he he did the tweet that was based
on the joke about her himself herself.
And so I'd say from that you might actually get towards some
argument for
for what do you call it?
Punitive damages, right? I think isn't that the isn't that what
happened to Alex Jones? Like he just continued to like fight
the law and uh [__] around in his court case until
they eventually like had piled up additional things on him.
I I think that's a thing. You laughed like three times about
her crying on the stand. Oh, well. Yeah, he's just a total piece
of [__]
I was taking screenshots of tweets mentioning her that were parodying
things he said on stream. Oh. Yeah, sure. That would be a probably
be pretty good if you send those to Pixie's legal team. I'd I'd
just leave that to Saibot though, okay? Or maybe send them to
He's gone full Trump. Life is art and watching Destiny and DGG
turn into MAGA and Trump is pure cinema. It's pretty funny, but
like also it sucks cuz I know a lot of people who are getting
hurt. I'm getting hurt technically. But uh I don't know. I'm
just I'm just like
I Guys like a total piece of [__]
It's So if I so if I'm on like the subway if I'm if I'm I'm riding
the subway and let's say there's a woman standing near me wearing
a skirt and I want to stick my finger in her butt crack. But
it would be weird to ask her.
So there's no there's no way for me to obtain the consent. So
the So it is therefore ethical for me to That's his cooking.
this is Hold on, that's his cooking. Well, tell you tell me what
he was sharing nudes of Pixie. He was sharing a video of himself.
Oh. Pixie was just an innocent bystander. Or well, she was just
an unidentified third
It wasn't Destiny that said, "Hey, this is a video of Pixie sucking
my dick." Or "Here's a video of Pixie." He was a girl asked him
if he had any videos of him getting his dick and or sorry, I
guess I should say So, your new argument is that he didn't need
her consent because she wasn't involved.
Actually, yes. I like that a lot more. Yes, he did not need her
consent because SHE WASN'T INVOLVED.
THIS IS SO YEAH, DUDE. NO, YOU DIDN'T need 40 minutes. I'm sorry,
you didn't need 40 minutes. It's immediately recognizable.
Like, come on, dude. Why are people Why are people just making
[__] up?
We know you were already off his dick
when LS stuff first leaked. Um I will be honest with you, S S
S S S. Uh I was friends with him and while when the Lauren Southern
stuff leaked alone, I was like I felt so bad for him. I felt
so so so bad. I was like, "Bro, some stuff got leaked. Like,
it's super personal. I don't know if it's real, man, but like
I'm giving you a heads-up. This [__] leaking is pretty
uh like you need to message people and like tell them, 'Hey,
this is going to be out there.' I would suggest doing that cuz
it's like it's fucked."
I felt bad for him. Cuz I'm a Okay? I felt bad for this idiot.
I think you're either trolling me or out of your [__]
mind. like that a lot. It was really I think we're done here.
Say your final thing and then I'm going to end the call.
I thought we made a lot of progress.
I'm glad you feel that. All right. Well, I appreciate you having
me on and uh I hope you keep doing your thing with Black Lotus
stuff. Don't listen to the haters and uh you know, I love your
stuff. Love what you do.
Do you think that's like cults but pretending not to be? So,
here's uh here's one of Pixie's responses to one of Destiny's
things from uh earlier. I think this is in the first week of
May. So, a full month ago.
Uh response paragraph seven. This is is extremely misleading
and mostly false. Although I did not object to him showing the
videos to Melina, I was very clear that they should not be shared
with anyone else. I was also clear that I would only share them
with my former boyfriend. This is also false because he knew
I had not I I had not had and did not have other sexual partners,
but rather just my former boyfriend.
Like this was the sharing thing that happened, right? And but
Pixie literally said, "I made it clear to him that I would only
share them with my former boyfriend." Which is also very clear
when Pixie says in 2014, "The only person who knows on my end
is my former boyfriend."
Right? And Destiny says, "No, the only person who knows on my
end is Melina."
When was the Destiny merch thing before or after the leak? After
all of the leaks, Captain Cappy Bants. After all of the leaks.
called by actual cult or just trolling me by pretending to be
cult?
Can't tell. Yeah, that's
That guy is so dumb. I'm actually not sure that that's really
his his actual opinion. That was such a dumb conversation. I
think that guy was just trolling me the whole time. How does
Extreme Dad always always force that response? He always affects
that response. Every time.
I think this guy is too to take seriously. Like I think I think
he's actually trolling me.
Uh okay. All right. That was a fun little thing. It was a very
fun little thing.
What's up next? I I might go and look at that response at some
point later today. We'll see if I'm going to do that or not.
I'm not I'm not 100% sure. Cuz they did a response to the confidentiality
or confidentiality order thing. And they took the clip of me
laughing.
I I don't know if I addressed it on stream yet or not.
Maybe I'll read that really quickly just in case other people
join later and I don't want to read these things.
There was the um response in opposition. Yeah.
So they oppose I guess the What is this? The protective order?
Defendant Steven K. Bonnell's opposition to plaintiff's motion
for protective order governing discovering discovery.
Uh introduction and factual background. I All I was going to
point out was they have a footnote here with a clip from my stream.
Uh one of the plaintiff's witness on an online streamer known
as Jstock is repeatedly cited in plaintiff's filings as allegedly
fearful of harassment and doxxing. See motion for protective
order here and here. In support of her motion, plaintiff submitted
a screenshot from Jstock that redacted a screen name but left
his distinctive avatar plainly visible. Despite the claim of
fear, Jstock later live streamed a segment in which he mocked
plaintiff's failure to properly redact the exhibit and openly
identified himself as supposedly as the supposedly anonymous
witness. See here. This conduct directly undermines any claim
that Jstock genuinely fears identification. To the contrary,
his public embrace of the role, ridicule of plaintiff's motion,
and display of the exhibit to his audience underscores that the
plaintiff cannot meet her burden to show good cause under rule
26C. Uh by the way, I would say in whatever um in whatever protective
order they do, any I think it would be totally fair and I would
suggest Pixie side offer this cuz then Destiny loses his argument.
I think Destiny should be able to respond to anything I say on
stream about him.
Like obviously, right? If I'm saying something in the public
about Destiny, he should absolutely have the right to respond
to that publicly.
Right? If I And I'm not talking about court filings. I'm saying
that if I say, "Hey, Destiny did this." then he can
Destiny is just being totally untruthful here. I just want to
be Watch this in Hold on. Let me Let me pull up exhibit B
They go to great lengths to protect this
clearly heroic individual's identity. Um so let me see let me
just see Oh wow. I don't know who this could possibly you know
what?
Yeah, but here's the thing.
No person This argument is so dumb. I'm glad that they projected
this person's hold on hold on. This argument is so dumb. I'm
starting to believe that the theory that his lawyers are just
milking him and doing every dumb thing he asks. Oh yeah, they
absolutely are but the funny thing about this is like
Who could possibly think that anyone here is arguing that my
pseudonym my online pseudonym needs to be protected from Destiny?
Or that my statements need to be protected from Destiny. I literally
speak publicly on this stuff, right? Nobody's making that argument.
Nobody's once made that argument. The thing that I would want
protected is my actual real identity which to testify or give
any statement I would have to give, right? That's the only thing.
I'm fine with Destiny knowing that I did this and the other thing
about this is it's literally saying even if they redacted everything
here. Do you mind if I say that I sat down with your lawyers?
I just wanted to say it Brettler just filed a motion in opposition.
I'm going to say this is precisely why I refuse to give an affidavit
because docs myself plus Destiny calling for my death is too
He knows that it's obvious that it's me in this text, right?
Hoping the judge won't see it that way I suppose. Well, the judge
would have to hear arguments on this and this argument is just
factually indisputable.
Right? I'm literally saying I'm going to say on my stream publicly.
Publicly that I did this, right?
And then they're literally on May 9th. I publicly say that I
did that.
Like I literally on May 9th or May 10th. I publicly say on the
stream this is what happened. So it's like docs myself plus Destiny
calling for my death is too much. Yeah, well Destiny's only called
for the death of four people and probably only one of those people
streamed about and talked about the motion on February or sorry
on May 9th.
I do think this whole court order for Kiwi Farms is Kiwi Farms
is insisting on a court order for no reason as far as I know,
and going out of their way to to consent to give the court jurisdiction
over them for the purposes of the order. Like why are they not
just removing it on their own? I don't know.
I think it's well, sorry. I think Null is saying that
they don't want it to be that people can just ask them to remove
things. Because then there's a bunch of things on Kiwi Farms
where people would just ask to have them removed, right?
So he says, "Okay, if you get a court order, I'll do it. But
I'm not like without a court order, I'm not doing it cuz I'm
not opening up the the floodgates on that, right? Like I'm not
going to respond to other people who are going to say, 'No, you
did it. You're just bending to pressure, public
He doesn't want that.
Hopefully the transcripts get unsealed. Well, I don't even really
care. OMG, he's pro. Like I don't know, unless the uh unless
the transcripts come out soon,
I literally don't really care.
Like we're we're just going to have the outcome of the preliminary
injunction
Right? We're just going to have the
Like this was just this was like an adjacent hearing. No matter
what happens from this preliminary injunction hearing, like I
don't think it really changes the material
facts of the case at all.
Even hold on. But I think this is absolutely false that Pixie
shared anything without consent. But even if that were true,
Destiny would just counter-sue her in a different lawsuit, right?
That would be all. Desti- Destiny would just counter-sue her
in a different lawsuit. That this would still proceed the exact
way it is now. So like literally none of that matters at all.
yeah, so unless those transcripts get uh released soon, if we
have the outcome of the preliminary injunction hearing, I don't
really need transcripts.
I don't know, I don't care. Is it legal for KF to host revenge
porn
Uh, there's some They They do an argument that it's in the public
interest because it's a like news story.
Uh, that didn't work for Gawker very well. I'd imagine if you
got Kiwi Farms on like some bad [__]
Yeah, you might be able to You might be able to get them to do
it.
It might be without explicit consent like she told him she would
be sharing it with her ex. Hold on though. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Pensive Goat, that is explicit consent.
I'm sorry. That's like a different There If it's not explicit
consent, it's something um it's something adjacent to explicit
consent and above implicit consent,
If somebody goes If If you say, "I'm going to share it with this
person." they go, "Eh." That's them consenting to it being shared,
right? If you If you have their attention, you say it directly,
and they go, "Eh." or "Yeah, okay." That's them consenting explicitly.
Uh, I feel like a judge is not going to is not going to want
to hear that Nulls is forcing a court to get involved when he
is willing and able to remove it anyways just because he doesn't
want to deal with takedown requests.
Hold on.
Is that true?
No, I think I think he's Like obviously he would have the ability
to fight a court order, right?
He's saying get a court order to have the stuff taken down. I
feel like probably, and you know, this sucks to be Destiny who's
somebody everybody hates, right? But I feel like if Destiny got
a court order to take those videos down, I think I think for
the Destiny like solo videos, I I think Null would just say,
"Fuck you. We'll take you to court. We'll see you in court."
Right? I think he would actually fight that order
Uh, I don't think I don't think they're going to lose the Dude,
going back to the preliminary injunction stuff, I think only
one of those four causes for the preliminary injunction I had
any faith would be granted at all. Two of them are just like
they don't even need to be granted. They're kind of Uh the first
one is going to be subsumed into the protective order stuff.
So, I'm not sure that it's even valid. And I believe Destiny
said the judge said this. Somebody said the judge said this that
the first one, the one that was actually potentially valid, I
think that one is just going to be subsumed into the protective
order arguments. And I'm not even sure that they're going to
make a ruling on the first one.
Or they they might just say we're denying it and it will be subsumed
into the like we're denying, you know, the the last three and
the first one will be subsumed into the protective order
Because for the uh for the first one was basically trying to
gag Destiny, prevent him from speaking on a couple of the things.
I think the sec I can't remember if it was the second or third
one is trying to force him to get a trying to force him to take
it down from other websites. I can't remember off the top of
my head. And then the last one was spoliation. Spoliation's already
illegal. You can't just delete evidence, right? That's already
illegal. So, getting like a court order to say you can't delete
any more evidence, well, that's just kind of silly, right?
But uh in any case, nothing from that except some of the evidence
that's been presented there is going to even be relevant to the
rest of the case.
You can recover electronic stuff though. Well, you can and hopefully
they do.
We'll see how it goes.
Oh, is something going on, court listener? Hold on. Sorry, dead
air time.
Trying to say, so I believe Destiny it was May 3rd that Pixie
filed her stuff where it had the part where she was saying, "Yeah,
I shared it with my
Did they respond in opposition to that
So, this is Pixie replies in support of motion re 21. 21 is what?
21 is the initial TRO preliminary injunction one. So, I guess
that's all a part of this.
I don't know if Destiny's
group had like an explicit um
opposition to this.
Like an opposition to Pixie's thing.
Oh, yeah. Evidentiary oppositions, hold on. That's what this
is.
So, their opposition here is declarant lacks personal knowledge
and foundation federal rules of evidence 602.
Oh, wait wait wait. Is this not it? That's not it. Hold on.
They go after this one? If they if they filed an opposition,
I thought that was it, paragraph seven. Hold on. Let me let me
go look again. I think it is para- It is paragraph
This is extremely misleading.
So, this one they don't even quote the part of the statement
where Pixie says, "I obviously had consent to send it to my boyfriend."
if they don't even quote that, and are there duplicates? Are
there any duplicates here? Do they respond to the whole paragraph?
So, here they don't do dot dot dot.
Oh, no, they do. Hold on. Hold on.
They just don't have a quoted. Okay, so they they did have some
opposition to Declarant lacks personal knowledge and foundation.
So, they did they did oppose this, I guess, but it was explicitly
something that was said.
Lacks personal knowledge and foundation.
I don't even know I don't know exactly what that Federal Rules
of Evidence 602.
Need for personal knowledge.
A witness may testify to a matter only if evidence is introduced
sufficient to support a finding that the witness has personal
knowledge of the matter.
Evidence to prove personal knowledge may consist of the witness's
own testimony. This rule does not apply to a witness's expert
testimony under Rule 703.
Uh I mean, is this even a valid objection to saying like it was
a personal conversation we had when you're testifying to the
outcome of a personal conversation?
Can you say, "Oh, they don't have personal
Is that a valid objection? Somebody could tell me if you actually
follow this stuff at all.
So, they opposed it on those grounds, but I don't know if that's
opposing the
matter of Pixie saying that yeah, I I I had a permission to share
it with my
I'm not sure.
What to next? Where do we go next, guys? Where are we going?
What are we doing? Where are we going?
I might do the Amaranth stuff here.
Hold on. I also need to check I need to get my uh
my Amaranth stuff set up here real quick. Again, they could really
be in a lot of trouble. This person's apparently been threatened.
WHOEVER THIS PERSON IS COULD HAVE BEEN IN A LOT OF TROUBLE if
their identity was exposed IN ANY WAY.
THE NAME IS REDACTED, YES. THE NAME is redacted. The avatar is
not redacted.
Now, it was going to be Let like Let's be real. It was going
to be obvious who it was just from the um Like it literally like
the the quotes like referenced earlier on. Okay?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm sorry. It's like It's just very
very very funny that like They're They're like not saying the
name. They're protecting the I click on this and it says my [__]
But like realistically
I there's no reason to suspect
Pixie doesn't have personal knowledge if it was cleared to Destiny.
Okay. Got you. Got you. Got you.
See Elon bragging to Stephen Miller that he stole his wife and
then deleting the
Uh I did not see that. But I did see somebody say to Stephen
Miller that Elon's your wife right now.
Which I do find very funny.
That whole thing's tearing itself apart. It's good stuff.